Hello everyone. This is Ann, practitioner and genetic specialist here at Connors Clinic.
And this genetic video today is going to be on the NRF2 and keep one pathway.
So when we're talking about NRF2 and keep one, we are really talking about some important players
as far as longevity is concerned. So these are some key genes to overall health and longevity.
They really code for survival. Both the NRF2 and keep one gene work together
to modulate the antioxidant defense system. And we'll get into details on how that happens.
And this is necessary to keep the balance of free radicals from being too overwhelming for
the system. And these genes are also important in detoxification. They code for genes that activate
detoxification. Also important for inflammation balance. And on your genetic report, this is what
the NRF2 and keep one genes look like. So obviously if you have ones and twos in the variant column,
then you know you have variants on some of these key genes that we're talking about here.
And then this metric here is showing you how common it is to have that exact variant that you have.
So you can get an idea of how common it is to have those variants. And if you do have variants and
either one of these categories, we do want to make sure we are addressing these. So we are
activating these as much as possible. So we can code for all of the things that are important for
longevity. And now we'll kind of start talking about that. So this is basically how it works.
I mentioned that keep one and NRF2 gene work as a pair. So they're kind of linked up to each
other. And the keep one gene is actually kind of the controller of NRF2. So you can see here this is
the nucleus. So this line here is kind of dividing the interior area as the nucleus. And this is
the cytoplasm. So NRF2 and keep one are kind of roaming around in the cytoplasm. They are just
kind of gathering information and sensing things. If they sense oxidative stress,
then what happens is keep one and NRF2 kind of uncouple. Keep one uncouples from NRF2,
which allows NRF2 to become activated. And then it travels into the nucleus of the cell here
where it can bind with sections of our DNA. And by binding to these sections of DNA,
it increases expression of certain genes. And these are the genes that we're activating the genes
that are coding for our antioxidant defense systems. So glutathione, SOD, catalase, all of these
things that your body can produce to then get to work and try to manage that oxidative stress.
So we're managing free radicals. We're reducing inflammation. And again, it's important for detoxification
of certain things as well. So that is how it works. They're coupled up, floating around, waiting for
any signals of stress. And then once again, if stress is identified, the keep one releases the NRF2
so we can go into the nucleus, bind to sections of DNA, then we have coding to produce these things
that help in this whole system that encourages longevity. You know, we don't want anything left unchecked
to cause damage within the body. Otherwise, the body's going to break down. We are going to age faster.
We're going to have a lot of signs and symptoms of aging and just degeneration of the body,
you know, things like cancer, autoimmune disease, Alzheimer's disease, Parkinson's disease, all
of these things that we try to ward off. They're really being helped by this NRF2 and keep one pathway.
And here is another diagram here. So it's a little small. Hopefully you guys can see that. But this is
kind of NRF2 at the center. Here is the keep one gene. So this is indicating keep one is controlling
or modulating expression of NRF2. And then when NRF2 is being stimulated or coding for, then
all of these arrows, you know, the ones that are going outward, it's indicating what NRF2 is
helping to modulate. So we have NADPH production. This helps with recycling of antioxidants. We have
glutathione production and regeneration over here. These are all the genes that hold for that.
Straight up at the top here, we have glutathione utilization. So these are all different genes involved
in glutathione utilization. We have H-mox. So this is involved in iron. So if we have variants in
the H-mox gene, we can have heme. That's involved with heme breakdown. And if we have variants,
we don't break down heme appropriately. And heme can become a free radical then. So it's involved in
neutralizing that, the heme free radical. And let's hear thyro-thyro-doxin. So this is another
antioxidant that is involved in kind of glutathione production and getting rid of, you know, the
potential of hydroxyl free radical. So NRF2 is doing all of these things. And you know, here's some
genes here. This is one of the brachogynes. So brach the brachogyne is going to stimulate NRF2
production. This gene here is going to stimulate NRF2 as well. So this is kind of a nice little
diagram to just see like all of the little touch points that NRF2 and keep one ultimately are involved
in. And ways that we can support this, if we do have variants. So this in this example here, we have
a red circle around keep one. This is indicating, we've got a lot of variants here. And then the NRF2
gene itself is yellow. So we've got some issues here. So we definitely need to support these
because with the red here, ultimately keep one is kind of bound more tightly when you have variants
and keep one. It's bound more tightly to NRF2. So it's hard for those two to separate and allow
the NRF2 to get into the nucleus where it's coding for all of these good things that we've talked about.
So definitely don't want variants in these genes. If you do have variants, things that we can do
to support these would be a regular exercise. Great way to stimulate and support NRF2 and keep one
variants. Curcumin or turmeric is very helpful for this. EGCG, which is the active component in
green tea. Also very helpful for this. Works to reduce inflammation, broccoli sprouts are
something that you can incorporate into your daily diet. You can throw broccoli sprouts into smoothies.
You can top your salads with some broccoli sprouts or vegetables, put it on sandwiches, whatever
you're doing, broccoli sprouts are pretty neutral in taste. You don't need a lot of them, but pretty
easy to incorporate into your diet and that has a lot of benefit. So for a faint as well,
that's the active component in broccoli. So for a faint helps to modulate these genes as well.
So hopefully this gives you a little bit of insight into the NRF2 and keep one pathway and why
it is important. All right, we will talk again soon. Bye-bye.